i hope you know uh if we
find out more about the details of uh
you know what might have caused
his early death um that if it is
something to do with being overworked or
anything the lifestyle that i hope it
does make a change if it is yeah we
don't know that obviously we might
never know but if we do find out more
details and it becomes publicly
available
and we you know we know that maybe being
overworked yeah
yeah i think it'd be good to at least
you know kind of put into the public
discussion right because you know
you know even if you are uh you know you
have because normally with uh heart
problems and this kind of blood stuff
it's normally there is some hereditary
stuff at play yeah
but i mean still at 54 is young like
that yeah my
lifestyle would have to have player
i just want mine because they're not not
have so much stress
on their body where it fails you know
yeah i don't know i feel bad man
it makes me feel shitty yeah yeah i mean
it's it sucks because i you know there's
not really much i can add to that
because
manga artists work a hell of a lot we
know we know they're getting we
we we know they work whether voluntarily
or not the deadlines that they set
themselves or set on them
too much yeah and it doesn't help that
fans are so demanding and that for some
[ __ ] reason the first question that
some fans have when an author dies is
what happens to the story
yeah like i mean it feels so selfish and
it feels that you know because we
we as fans also have something where
we're selfish and we want yeah
yeah yeah i don't know like surprisingly
from what i saw there weren't as
many of those in the comments it wasn't
enough it just showers you or your
taste when you see like even one yeah
every now and then i saw and i'm like
okay clearly you don't really give a
[ __ ] but
i mean not an upset of fans of great and
yeah i understand yeah
yeah there were just some of the
insensitive ones yeah but
it reminds me of uh but it's like when
there's earthquakes and stuff
right yeah people are always just like
oh the manga it's
delayed because of an earthquake and
it's like what do you mean
like people like people die like yeah
exactly
like earthquakes are no [ __ ] joke
exactly and it's like people that
most i mean you know obviously with this
situation is very sensitive you know and
it was very fresh and
people a lot of people care but i i
noticed especially with like earthquakes
and stuff the people
are very quick to be like oh who gives
you [ __ ] it's just an earthquake it
happens all the time yeah yeah yeah
and it's like well i think it plays into
the the overall
sentiment of that a lot of anime fans
and manga fans are very demanding for
the stuff that they want
yeah and i feel like we as fans either
chill out a little bit
yeah they they care about the product
but not so much about the person making
yeah i feel like we always found the
journey to
chill out about our passion for anime
and manga
i'd say external things happen they
happen it is what it is remember that
some actual person is making your
product yeah you know whether it be an
earthquake or personal stress they're
all valid reasons for work to be delayed
whatever you know i i just i just want i
just want creators to be able to create
the [ __ ] to the best of
you exactly and not have to worry i mean
it kind of reminds me of hope that's not
controversial for me to say i don't know
i don't know
i don't want to want a hot tub i feel
respect respect
staff members
no i mean i i'm sure everyone can agree
on it it's just
more you know we're i'm sure 99 percent
of people watching this
don't do that it's just that one percent
right now it's always that one percent
because i remember
this reminds me of like the game of
thrones thing with joara martin
where i remember like seeing an
interview with him
and he was he said that he got annoyed
that some people were
worried about his health not because
they were worried about his health but
they're worried if he would
be alive to finish game of thrones right
right and i'm just like yeah that's
pretty [ __ ] up
like fans are saying that to you aren't
they jesus christ yeah and even if they
didn't say it i'm sure he knows
that people are probably thinking yeah
he can repeat between the lines yeah
yeah of course yeah
i only care about his well-being in
terms of the book like he's being
[ __ ] held hostage by the story
yeah like you know what i mean you can't
[ __ ] do anything if anyone knows the
intention of game of thrones fans it's
the guy who made kevin harris
that's just sad that's just sad i don't
know yeah it's like this makes me sad
for like many reasons you know there's
just so much at play
this does this this is what i mean it's
a sad topic unfortunately it's all about
the respect
yeah that's all it is just respect the
creators respect the artists
yeah give them some space if they're
feeling sick or need a break